and here we are one heat pump
and how long have you had it for
six months
Nigel Murphy has ditched the gas boiler
and gone for an electric heat pump it's
working effectively in his
well-insulated house but even with a
government grant it cost him six
thousand pounds
it's not a cheap thing to do yeah I mean
fine if you have if I had an accountant
either told me not to do it because the
payback on it
is going to take some years before you
know you get to a break even The Man Who
provided Nigel's heat pump says this is
a major reason why the pace of
installation is so slow families are
forced to make a decision between the
cost of living and green living the
level of support for heat pumps isn't
enough five thousand pounds doesn't
bridge the gap in the cost between a
boiler installation and a new system
that's required for the heat pump
installation
frustration reflected in a scathing new
report by the independent climate change
committee criticizing the government's
sluggish delivery on home heating grid
upgrades onshore wind development tree
planting and much more
The Climate Change committee's Report
says that while there has been some
progress on the sale of new electric
cars and Renewable Power over all the
pace of progress is worryingly slow and
the committee says that it's confidence
the government is going to hit its Net
Zero targets Beyond 2030 is now markedly
less than it was a year ago
for the outgoing chairman it is a
squandered opportunity
it's not just that the United Kingdom
has lost its leadership in the world on
this issue it is that the United States
with its remarkable new legislation the
European Union with its very clear new
legislation and indeed China doing a
huge amount more they are the ones that
are going to get the investment they are
the ones that will get the new green
jobs the government has defended its
record in particular the decision to
encourage new drilling for oil and gas
in the North Sea about 76 percent of the
energy of the most decarbonized major
economy in the world us comes from
fossil fuels today there is no button I
can press that turns that off tomorrow
and as we will be dependent on oil and
gas for decades to come even as we move
to Net Zero it makes sense that we
should produce it here
it's just another example of how
complicated and challenging it is to
decarbonize
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News